hey guys it's the evident caitlyn
podcast the show where nothing's made up
and the points really matter
[Music]
are you keeping score today yes see but
it's also like a play on the words
clever you don't need to explain it
moving on today we're gonna be covering
some of our past DIY fails kind of
continuing the story from the last
podcast yeah we were gonna get into it
last time every we didn't have time and
then we're also gonna play the game
called shark tank yeah well like like we
pitch ideas just like in shark tank we
need to come up with a better name like
cuz it's all disclosure we are totally
taking this idea from the jenna julian
podcast they did it recently and it
seems super fun
we don't even watch shark tank oh i know
like what the show is its where you
pitch business ideas to your investors
and try to get them to invest in your
idea so our initial brainstorming around
it well we'll get into that later but
like we try to come up with like kind of
not the best ideas but we actually came
up with some good ones I mean we'll see
we'll see yeah but they're all like shop
slash maker slash filming I think he
doesn't film yeah so so we'll get into
that but first DIY oh yeah I think that
we already talked about in our last in
one of our previous podcasts how our
very first project was replacing the
pipes in their attic I mean that was the
first project on our house we had
started some stuff in the apartment yeah
yeah well here let's let's go back to
like our very very first like project we
tackled together and I think it kind of
might be a good story that
it might be a good story to share
because we often get some comments like
wow I like your workshop and you know
all those tools and stuff but I think
that must be nice having those tools but
I think it might be good to share that
like the very first project we tackled
we only have like one or two tools we
were living in an apartment
we did most of the work on our balcony
and on our living room floor and yeah we
totally made some good stuff and the
balcony was like three feet by five feet
it was very small she's not really
exactly it might be four foot by like
seven foot it's definitely not bigger
than our shed yeah pretty small it was a
small apartment balcony so I think the
the very first project that we tackled
was well here let's get into the
backstory that's the tiny bit we were
out like a wedding show because we are
thinking about getting married oh no we
were at a wedding show for one of our
friends yes we were not engaged we had
kind of talked about getting married but
we hadn't told anyone yet that we knew
we were gonna get married
oh yeah and one of my best friends was
engaged and so she was like come to this
wedding expo and so he came with her and
a couple other friends and we saw these
big light-up marquee letters and this is
like in 2013 or something so they they
were just kind of like coming into trend
it was been like everyone was just
starting to see marquee letters pop up
and we were like oh okay I thought
Kalin's eyes literally light up she's
like I want that and they were so cool
and they were like two feet tall and
they're really big and but the people
who had those marquee letters they
rented them for hundreds of dollars yeah
just to rent them just to rent them like
hundreds of dollars and so for the
entire rest of the Expo we were just
brainstorming how we could make them and
we had never made anything together
before I hadn't really I'd done some
very small projects from my apartment
before we moved in together and you had
made stuff in general but we hadn't made
something together yeah and and made
stuff in general you know I'd always
wanted to be like kind of an inventor or
something like that and I had done like
giant engineering projects but I
actually hadn't done too many handy
things so what kind of engineering
didn't you do like a catapult or
something Oh College yeah oh that's an
engineering projects but like a catapult
right I'm
I made a catapult and bridge and some
other things there was once where I mean
a couple friends were like jogging on a
track during the phase where I was
trying to be healthy too long we were
jogging and we got water balloons
launched at us and it was in the like
middle of the night because you know we
thought it'd be a good idea to we never
found them we got like two or three
lunch they didn't hit us they just like
somewhere in the fields I'm pretty far
away and I was like I think you had a
t-shirt I was a business major and you
did a t-shirt that what did it say oh no
we don't need to bring that up it said
something like something encouraging
about engineers and dispiriting about
business yes just like the drama not
really that wasn't really drama I just
thought it was funny but but I think
that it like was my someone when I one
of the first times ride like gotten the
tools and just made something just for
myself or ourselves for the letters yeah
yeah I I don't know why I had that much
confidence don't know Pinterest was also
very new and fresh at the time and
there's a lot of like it was kind of the
DIY movement starting which yeah and
most of it was starting to save money
yeah most of it was starting to save
money I mean DIY and Pinterest got
really popular like around the same time
as the recession that happened around
our graduation yeah and so there's a lot
of people trying to save money and I
think that's when DIY blogs in DIY
projects and Pinterest DIY is all got
super popular um but anyways I think
that we haven't oh yeah so we said that
we made the marquee letter so yeah I
came up with like a design we bought the
wood I think all we had was a jigsaw
some rulers sharpies and a drill yeah
and we just made it work yeah we got
like a plastic sawhorse yeah and at that
time were we doing the blog right then
No
when we started them we didn't start the
blog until we got the house oh yeah our
first post was about buying the house
yeah and we did those letters over a
period of like a year and a half
starting out if it's taking a long time
that's normal
yeah yeah and that was like a pretty
ambitious build I would say forever
still two foot tall letters wood and
metal with lights yeah we we hammered in
by hand
hundreds of nails around the perimeter
to hammer in the metal flashing into the
wood yes same time around we we used the
nail gun and if you guys um aren't
picturing what we're talking about with
these marquee letters we have a video on
them so we'll link it if you want to see
what they look like as we remade them
for the channel cuz it's still like one
of our favorite projects yeah and for
when we had our blog yeah we were
bloggers not really we just didn't like
as a hobby that was supposed to blow up
the most it got thousands of pins and it
got some traction going on Pinterest
yeah we if you see letters on Pinterest
it's ours and and and I think for a
while there if you search marquee
letters do I on Google we were like one
number one or number two yeah yes I
think we're like number two right behind
the HGTV post and it was like so I think
that was like the first thing that we
tackled before we moved into our house
right I don't think there's really
anything else we did in our apartment
yeah I mean I I in my apartment did this
thing that I saw in Pinterest where you
like attach four little pieces of like
one by dowels into a frame and then you
stretch fabric over them and then you
hang them on your wall so it's just like
squares of fabric I don't know why that
was I had them up for like a couple of
weeks and I was like why didn't I just
paint something that was so much easier
it looks so much better I don't know
like by a canvas and paint something
yeah easier cheaper better looking
Oh Evans turning down my volume I guess
I'm getting a little enthusiastic little
passionate about this fabric squares
that I made
I didn't even know about that they were
on my old blog Oh your old blog and I
started before we started our blog it's
still out there somewhere
yeah all right so I think after the pipe
replacement I think the next thing that
we tackled was fixing all the insulation
there well many people haven't listened
to the pipe replacement story just that
was the first one in our that we did in
our new house our first project we
basically like feared that we had we had
like existential crisis moments in the
Attic that I think one of the very first
things we did is I built a bridge over
our AC unit oh yeah so that we could get
to the pipes yeah I mean like with
latches and hinges and stuff so you
could like take it apart and put it off
like crawl over this giant air duct like
big square air duct no it wasn't just
something you could step over you had to
sit on it and climb over yeah and since
we had people that might be going into
our attic that might not be as careful
as us it's like we don't want something
to sit in on our air ducts because you
see that people had just like sat on it
okay thin metal there's no like
structural support in there it's not
meant to take wait yeah so we went to
the store and we were like okay this is
just in the attic what's the cheapest
wood we can just like that bright so we
have pink bridge oh yeah and we had to
make also some like little walkways for
ourselves too didn't have any walkways
in our attic we most of our projects
when we first bought the house were in
the Attic in the Attic and I think it
was summer it was summer and I think the
next thing that we tackled because like
our house is kind of old and it has
gotten a lot of work done on it that and
I feel like the work wasn't done with
the utmost care there is like batting
ripped down like their bare walls there
are piles piles of wires piles of like
trash it was just all in the Attic
and the the recessed lights that had
been installed in their house weren't
insulation contact rated yeah so we
couldn't just like blow insulation up
there the soffits weren't right we had
install soffits we had install like all
of that we had to build little shrouds
around our ceiling lights what are those
oh yeah then I forgot them a few seconds
later we did all that we blew insulation
and that Ryan it worked you know we did
it yeah but that was like one of the
most daunting things yeah blowing our
own insulation not that blowing part
although that was like pretty physically
and intensive for you all the prep I
remember like we had to get these you
know there's all these things you have
to do so that the insulation doesn't go
where you don't want it to go and having
insulation in Texas is really important
this is a high priority project for us
to do first but there's all these things
that you have to do to keep it in place
so we did have to build these little
boxes around each of our recessed lights
because they weren't rated for
insulation contact we had to put these
little vents in our soffits and to do
that it's like you know you look at this
old house we wore helmets you look it up
on this old house and it just looks like
oh you just pop them in and it's so easy
and then you do it yourself and you're
like whoa there's about five inches from
my head to be right there and there's
nails coming through the ceiling so we
were like hardhats beli proudly wore
hard hats because I hit my head on those
nails multiple times intense so intense
like so many I was freelancing at the
time too so there's a lot of times where
you are at work and I was up there by
myself like in the Attic literally belly
crawling with a head lamp and like hard
hard hat and my boots and I would had to
be in long sleeves and long pants
because there's so much insulation I
wish we had been making YouTube videos
we have a couple like little clips and
we have photos because we we documented
all of it so you have a ton of photos
but it was just like
such an intense introduction to home and
it was also we did all this work and
then you can't see any of it yeah it's
all hidden in the there's no real payoff
except for your electricity bill yeah
and even that like we did it the first
summer so we don't really have a
before-and-after we're doing yeah but
Wow yeah lots lots of hills lots of
struggles sorry Matt nog fails lots of
struggles and you know there's always
like the usual like first Home Owner
things like clearing a clogged toilet it
was not us that clogged it you make it
sound like we did terrible things I was
not it was one of those a company that
we hired to help lay our floors right it
was one of the floor people yeah and it
was right before we left on vacation too
yeah so so we come back from from making
where did we bring up the story in the
past okay all right we don't wanna bring
it up too much
no no we didn't we didn't tell the story
we didn't tell the story you just said
poopy water and I was like you gotta
explain if I was gonna say the words
poopy water um
okay let me get into the mental state to
tell the story okay everyone who is like
freaked out by like potty talk skip
forward should I tell it three minutes
so teller should not tell it it was a
traumatic experience caring caring poopy
water tell the story you can't say
things like that out of context I'm at
work and and so on her house unbeknownst
to us one of the people here had used
the restroom the dust pet restroom the
guest restroom and shortly after they
left we we hadn't fully unpacked yet so
we had had a bunch of stuff shoved all
over the house into the rooms that
weren't getting the floor is done and
one of those rooms was the guest
bathroom and literally the
after they left we went on vacation we'd
already had it planned it was just kind
of poor timing and we were rushing and
so we weren't using that bathroom
because we had had a bunch of stuff in
that so we were just using the other one
so we came back after a week and a week
a week and I go to open that bathroom -
the door is locked which is really weird
so I finagle it I get it open and then I
realized what has been done in there and
it was in there for the entire week and
like it was one of those things are like
trying to like turn the key to turn the
water off and you're freaking out you
couldn't put a plunger in there I had to
put on gloves and I had to get a solo
cup okay and I had to transfer things
[Laughter]
move on to another time attic experience
for Kaitlyn sauerkraut let's tell the
story of the shower go yeah yeah calm
down drama poopy water so our master
bedroom shower had like really bad grout
job yeah yeah I do you um yeah I just
had like the there was some mildew in
the crowd and it was like cracked a lot
and in some places it was almost like it
they used caulk instead of grout because
it was different textures in some places
it was like oh there's like both sauce
over grout
it was really weird so I was like you
know what I'm just gonna scrape out the
top layer of everything and we'll just
redo it ourselves because that's what
the internet told me to do again made it
look super easy and I got started in
like once you start you feel committed
to keep going because you've already
started like messing it up that's the
thing with DIY projects a lot of times
you have to mess it up before you're
fixing it yeah and once you're in the
messing it up phase back and the master
shower is way better than the gushed
shower so it's like we want to use that
yeah well we weren't just gonna like not
use our master shower in our brand new
house so again I was working from home
so I was just hours and hours of I
remember I remember like you use all
sorts of different scrapers and tools in
one day almost like and they're trying
to help you out or something and I
looked at like utility knife blade but
you know like you know what the ones are
the replaceable blades and everything
Caitlin that scraped it so much it was
not even at a point it had like an
eighth inch like radius to it
she had scraped off like an eighth of an
inch of metal I was craving this grout
it's completely round so many tools I
just wore down to the bone metal ward
it's like she was like sanding them with
the sand in the ground anywhere I was
spending hours wearing down metal tools
my hair dryer in there I think like
there are parts of the caulk or are like
I dread a tip that was like if you heat
it up it's easier to peel on the pills
are so hot a bunch of blades billion
warned all adults I was right hanging
out there I watched like several seasons
of the office in the background just
watch it are just working on that with
those
just to give you a measure of time it
was like at least a few seasons you
trying to do that and then finally I
gave up we hired someone to come redo
things it's bad it's bad
ya know I don't know if there's any
lessons learn from that there's no
there's no lesson side it's just sharing
the traumas so you guys aren't alone if
you guys have gone through pain
yeah well cuz I feel like and I read a
lot of DIY blogs and stuff and it's like
yeah they hits you know little struggles
here and there but I feel like they
always figured it out in the end there
are some things I was like I'm just not
I'm not getting to the end well one
thing that worked out pretty well is all
of the DIY we did for our wedding and
Caitlyn did all of the planning herself
and we did oh my gosh guys she was so
organized she had packets for everyone
on the wedding day they did she had like
like like every person got it
personalized I got a packet everyone got
a packet it was almost like like psych
some people were grouped into categories
but some people got an individual packet
with like what they had them like like
what they're responsible for and
everything so then everyone knew like oh
I don't need to worry about that because
that's covered by someone else and
everyone could be a little bit less
stressful and in everyone's packet it
said what do all the other
responsibilities were and who was
responsible for them so you needed to
find that person you could find that
person that all the boxes were labeled
and it said who was responsible for what
boxes so you could find your boxes guys
how many boxes there were in your group
there was like one of three two of three
our wedding venue place was like do you
want to work for us I actually
considered getting into like wedding
planning after our wedding because I was
really good at it we're really good at
it but a lot of what we did was making
stuff for wedding we made all the
decorations we made like a backdrop we
made a paper lantern chandelier we did
we did all the centerpieces we did the
marquee letters that was the first thing
we did for a wedding
um yeah a lot of stuff a lot of stuff oh
my gosh Steve
I kind of forgot about the backdrop we
hadn't written that down to talk about
that yes we so we did a photo backdrop
Evan made the frame it was like this
these 2x4 stands and then we did a
curtain rod across the top ooh but over
the stands I like just just to toot my
own horn here it was cool cuz like they
needed to be really sturdy but they
couldn't be like assembled until they
were on site so I made it with like all
these pins and everything so I you'd
like put things into place yet but pins
through the brackets and you'd put the
little lock pin on the backside and
everything so it was kind of cool
they're very smartly assemble Lobel yeah
and I took fabric and I ripped it into
long strips and I hand dyed it to make
like an ombre there are a lot of like
when like fails and struggles within
that too well for the wedding your
responsibility it was even even in terms
of the build like you know and you know
all the dyeing and oh yeah well I did
all of them and then realized they
weren't long enough because they shrank
up so then I had to do extensions so
there's like safe to do color match a
safety pin to the backend add a color
match and all this stuff but yeah done
the day of it was incredibly windy and
we had all these tassels and that was
gonna be behind us mm-hmm so I think I
had to make the call to use that I was
like a photo backdrop instead of the
wedding backdrop yeah because it was
like super windy and and everything so
it's like kayln doll that would like tap
work and everything was good and on the
wedding day she was like all right
everything's handled but then huh you
know I had to kind of coordinate the
setup of everything and Kalyn had done a
wonderful job but things went wrong
things were going wrong it's like the
backdrop was getting all blown all over
the place and thankfully we had white
duct tape so like white duct taping like
everything down all the strips down and
and and all of that and then like all of
the like table settings were getting
blown everywhere and yeah on the
scrambling with that and the windows
creepy yeah the wind was crazy
well scrambling Oh like I
brought like videogames and I thought
it'd be like playing video games and
stuff and I was like scrambling and then
like at some point my groomsmen were
like haven't you got to go get changed
cuz like I wasn't like casual like
shorts and like a shirt and this was
like 40 minutes before the ceremony was
gonna start or something I know before
the the first let the first look so I
had like like hop in a car race to like
like your parents hotel room closer like
change like shower get ready run is like
the groom's suite where you hang out how
to shower oh another thing that the wind
messed up was another one of our DIY had
yeah so we made this super cool again
this was super Pinterest e popular at
the time but this paper lantern
chandelier we made in kind of like PEX
piping yeah well we had leftover PEX
piping after replacing the some of the
piping in our attic but guys PEX piping
is not sturdy so we had to like
reinforce it with like dowels and it was
like kind of janky but we made it work
we got it there it was essential we we
we made a hoop I feel like we need to
describe we made we made a big circle
that was maybe five or six feet in
diameter yeah and then we made spokes
like out of dowels for that circle to
keep it rigid because the PEX piping was
like flexible and we couldn't find a
hula hoop big enough that was the
original plan yeah but imagine something
that looks like a hula hoop with a bunch
of spokes and then we from the the pecks
hung fishing line with little hooks in
it and we hung paper lanterns of
different sizes and colors and Heights
so it made this really cool chandelier
eventually and it was awesome and we
thought like oh man wouldn't be even
cooler if it lit up at night you know
when there were actually lights in the
paper lantern Chandeleur so I 3d pie I
bought some like a little under closet
under cabinet under cabinet lights that
you'd push to activate and then I 3d
printed like
hooks on the back of them and then like
during testing they're falling off so I
use like Gorilla Glue to like super glue
them on and like it was getting janky
and janky as we went but on the day of
everything had been working well and we
raised the chandelier up and everything
was looking good but then it was so
windy that the paper lanterns kept them
falling down yeah well and the
chandelier was right above the center of
the decently heavy lights like if one of
those lights conked you in the head from
30 feet above it would hurt and they're
falling I think one even felt like right
before the reception started to work
people have been dancing yeah and I was
just like those numbers like please Lord
don't let these things fall and it did I
do think if I was going to not do one of
our DIYs it might have been the paper
lantern chandelier we're gonna do it
again now we could totally make it work
so well I know but that's different not
do because a little bit like expertise
expertise well we did we just didn't
know all the factors that might have
like affected it like with the wind and
everything it was just wind of nature we
weren't taking all that into account I
mean you know if we had have known that
there is wind we could have maybe wind
proofed it like tape things down more it
is duct tape everything duct tape
chandelier yeah well and i'm i think now
even you know in the yeah but almost
five years since we got married yeah
lights there's much better lights that
we could have put in there to turn it on
during setup which was in the afternoon
and have it still be lit by the evening
yeah so if we couldn't just deal with
the little cheapo LEDs they would have
gone out and we did a lot of research
did a lot of research yeah
and now I think an interesting thing
this isn't really a DIY but it does kind
of go back to the blogging days
is we wrote a post called house buying
for noobs oh yeah because we found the
process super confusing so confusing and
it was our first venture into doing like
non project-based stuff like guide
videos now when it comes to like selling
stuff you mean yeah but the house buying
for noobs we like broke it down and did
all the steps yeah I like you know use
personal anecdotes and all that because
it is super intimidating should we make
a youtube video I don't know I feel like
it's been a while we might have let's
wait till you buy another house and then
we can like we need fridge we need
footage yeah yeah yeah we have some
footage of right of our house ah ideas
but yeah but it was that was one of our
first posts I got that and the marquee
letters both got like kind of yeah
mm-hmm
fancy bloggers guys so when Kailen moved
in mokey came along and our supervisor
and we wanted to make like everything
look pretty and also give her a space to
do her business business so we made like
a cat box cabinet where we put like her
box we were in apartment so we didn't
that you know right now and a lot of
people will keep cat boxes in like a
laundry room or a mudroom yeah but in an
apartment we did not have that yeah so
we made that and it did pretty well on
Pinterest describe it we took an Ikea
cabinet like um it was a Kia best at
cabinet which is one of the ones that
they use for like media consoles where
it's very modular and you can buy like a
to unit or a three unit or a single unit
we we took a double unit and we cut a
cat door in the side and then we put her
litter box in one side and there's a
cabinet you could we could open to like
access it to clean it out and then the
other compartment there was like a
little litter mat and we cut a doorway
in the divider so she could go through
it was a drawer that had her stuff in it
and so it was super nice and it just
looked like a little um yeah little
console table almost and so before we
started doing YouTube videos we really
you know we should post this on reddit
but let's figure out reddit that's like
you know something because we were
lurkers but we had never posted anything
on really well just try able to test the
water so we did like we created an image
role I can't owned a reddit account we
posted it and all that stuff and we got
to the front page yeah we know how to do
yeah we know how to read it we know how
to read it we did it again waited again
with um her scratching post post that we
did on the blog which is just a little
flat one that's on the ground yeah and
we got to the front page again yeah
we're like oh man I know like when we
launched our YouTube channel we're gonna
do the same thing and we're gonna like
kick-start things and then we we tried
and it failed miserably
yeah so bad we even had like we were
like one to one okay let's do another
cat scratching post cuz we've been
wanting to do it anyway and that's the
one we're gonna post on reddit because
our first cat scratching posted well
reddit loves cats we love cats we have a
very cute cat let's take advantage of
that and so we're like okay we posted it
we had up like better photos and
everything so great and it totally
tanked but like the reason why I mean it
was a good learning lesson for reddit I
mean it's like it's because we were
trying trying when we weren't trying
people appreciated it but when we were
trying people didn't appreciate it yeah
and that's a whole I love reddit but I
don't like to post things yeah we'll
just keep on lurking yeah forever
lurking oh man well hey like we're a
decent amount of time in we should
probably move on to the game yeah game
show time
that's probably enough time for the
music that's enough time for the music
okay so once we call this maker shark
tank shark fail fail tank you got fail
tank fell tank yeah but you know I don't
want to go in with the expectation some
of these ideas might be actually a good
legit idea yeah
we've called the make tank make tank oh
but it's not always gonna be maker
fill thing fill tank okay fill tank
alright ready for my first idea yeah
okay so let's explain the rules because
some people might not know they might
not be familiar with the rules well no
no they might not be familiar with this
with the show shark tank I'm not I'm not
I'm not but I know the concept okay so
it's basically I think people pitch
their business or product ideas to a
panel of like three or so sharks who are
investors and they're trying to get them
to invest in their product they often
come with like a prototype or a sample
and pitch yeah and all that they're
trying to convince them to invest in
some way right ready yeah
good morning shark shark make I almost
like all right so today I'm coming to
you with my product it's called the
tornado the tornado tornado can you
spell that for me
tio are any ATO so what it is so you
know so imagine this you've been working
in the shop all day yeah and you're
tired and it's really messy now you
don't want to go around sweeping and
vacuuming that all up that's that's a
things ABS what you do is you just like
put everything away and you turn on your
tornado and what that does is this for
industrial sized fans and all four
corners of your shop that creates a
tornado inside your shop and then
there's a vacuum in the ceiling that
creates a vortex and sucks up everything
loose in your shop up through the
tornado and this cleans your entire shop
in a one go you know do you ever look
like a soldier system because I feel
like you're gonna lose a lot of valuable
things no so
there's a filter system so it won't
damage the tornado but I'm not worried
about damaging the tornado I'm worried
about like yeah you got a you got to put
everything back in their place and then
like like you just like do your work you
put your tools up in like whatever
containers they need to be or whatever
like that you turn your tornado from
it's clean I feel like that only works
if you have like a very specific
organization system that you sell with
it where like you don't care about
putting it up you don't put maybe I have
a cup that I put all my shot pencils in
which we do that's not gonna keep it out
of it no no see it'll be specifically
calibrated to pick up dust and dirt and
sawdust but not precise engineering
pending but wouldn't that be great it's
like even if you have to make
modification so your top a little bit
what's more painful cleaning your shop
constantly or organizing once I'm still
not convinced that you're not going yeah
you know you want it you want the
tornado ten million dollars I'm holding
out my hand everyone who's listening
okay looking at it suspiciously
I mean concept but it's just a matter of
like trusting how if you're like a mad
scientist or a good scientist I find you
to be very attractive thank you that
would be kind of nice right
everything is so secure because I don't
fully believe in your like calibration
calibration seems a little suspicious to
me but I see the future business
opportunity to turn it into a full
system a full shuttle system yeah yeah
wait like tight to it everything else is
like vacuum as when you turn on your
seals when you turn on your fans
everything else is like vacuum pulled to
their organization
like a vacuum chamber behind it so it
sucks everything it's all the same
system but you just go to like cabinets
and stuff you know you just have to use
keep all of yourself cabinet Edwards
no more back boards you're gonna peg
boards in your cabinets right oh we saw
a lot of cabinet sell the line of
cabinets to go with the tornado the
cab nito's good cab me though okay I
like I'm glad I have one for you to see
if there's anything else in my notes for
this attorney you sold me already
okay okay yeah you're right don't sell
past the yes don't sell pass the yeah
yeah yeah don't sell fast okay okay I
have one there's um it's called food
food or wood foot whichever
pronunciation you prefer it's gonna
rhyme food is it what do you eat it is a
blender that your dust collection auto
routes to this blender and it blends up
your sawdust into a healthy fiber that
you can add fruit juice or or veggies th
and you make a smoothie
it's sustainable it's roughage so it's
healthy have you done any medical trials
on this yes it's still working his way
through fiber I'm not think I don't
think they're actually saying fiber no
it's it's natural what about the glue
well you don't you have different nos
clutch and it's hooked up for anything
with glue would food its food food it's
like it's gonna be the new the new
flaxseed the wood food what you can do
is you can like termite owners are
really gonna love that you can just feed
the wood food straight to the turbine
for the termite food yeah it's it's
great it's it's a green sustainable
eco-friendly
option why don't you just use the the
would food for food food food why don't
you just use the the woodchips like to
create heat and like a furnace like
everyone else does because I want
smoothies okay I ready for this okay
Manny have you ever been in the middle
of a large grew up mm-hm and you're just
struggling with your glue bottle and
think there has to be a better way maybe
let me introduce you the super glue are
basically it's a super soaker filled
with wood glue that's not terrible
it sounds great it's like it's like you
need a fast glue up pull out your super
glue er it's all glued that sounds like
how you get glue on everything you don't
want glue on it's it's super precise
it's accurate to within 5 inches how can
you guarantee that I've tested it in
simulations how do you get the glue to
shoot out of the Super Soaker because
it's a lot more viscous than water
it's just pressurized air you know it
just shoots out yeah it kind of sounds
like the hot glue gun atomizes the ghost
atomizer yeah that means it's getting
into the air and it's getting on
everything it aerates it right at the
nozzle there's a specialized nozzle
where it mixes compressed air with a
stream of superglue
that just seems like less control
atomizes it and a fine mist and then you
don't even have to you don't have
afterwards I miss that only sprays in a
five inch radius does not go up into the
air like mists
do yes
they cost $500 each this isn't it
I I kind of want to make one though no
I'm already like imagining just like
attaching like a nozzle to a wood glue
bottle and like this is attaching like a
little air compressor to it it'll be
good yeah all right let's hear your idea
okay okay
it's called 4d printing it's 3d printing
but with scented filament we already
have that coffee-flavored filament all
at this yeah yeah while you're printing
it smells like you're brewing coffee
[Laughter]
brilliant I guess so I have an idea okay
5d printing you can eat it after yeah 60
printing I'm just standing in the garage
I'm trying to breathe okay are you ready
for this next idea I'm ready for this
jelly have you ever been in a filming
situation where you you don't want to go
back and forth to the camera you end up
filming too much too little you're
bothered by it
introducing the bike shops so what this
is is this is a remote that's waterproof
and you put it in your mouth on your
back molar and when you're ready to
start filming you just bite down and
then it's filming and once as soon as
you're done you bite down again minimize
its footage but you don't miss any
moments that you want you know what's so
weird what like like yesterday the day
before I was thinking about filming yeah
and I was thinking wouldn't it be so
much easier if I could just click a
button with my teeth what with my teeth
to turn on and off the camera
because I was like you don't know you
don't have your ham
what if you have other things exactly
you don't have your hand you can't like
blink at the camera because my first
thing was like you know like something
was like a blink but then yeah you blink
too much you can you can control and I
was like okay like a very specific bite
yeah right that's so weird I was like
for this exact purpose what for for for
the the note this was before we decided
to do failing what I was just thinking
about idea is that what's the I mean I
have to invest yeah it was my idea to
hey so I I've invested in two out of
your three and you've invested jump into
a companion idea so if this fails my
backup is voice no no let me see kami
kami the product is called kami now have
you ever been like like you know so even
if you have a screen like there's other
things you want to adjust what if you
want to adjust the ISO what if you want
to take a picture or a video or you want
to zoom in or zoom out kami kami it's a
smart camera it's a voice enabled camera
and you can ask it to start recording
stop recording zoom in zoom out change
the ISO bright and lower focus okay kami
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah
okay kami ISO 1600 yes yeah smart
cameras you mean voice control yeah
usually - good kami introducing kami
what's the one it was the one the bite
one was my shot because the bike shot is
like if you have an older camera yeah if
you have an older camera and you can't
afford kami by a chop but if you're like
new to the game and you want like
upgrade kami it's like it's like a group
it's like a family of products by shot
and kami guys we got a patent patent
these
boy like wouldn't that be great let me
so great your ideas way too practical
that's a great idea and like that the
technology is there you know it's like
you can control your camera over
Bluetooth and remote it's all told via
software voice recognition is already
there it's like the software exists a
hundred percent it make it cuz I often
think like man this would be so much
more like doing YouTube videos would be
so much more difficult when we're by
ourselves their goodness we have two
people but still even with two balls
kami kami is there do I have to take
again look shake of defeat okay let me
pull back a crappy idea okay oh no this
is good okay don't go all right you know
there's a lot of things what's one of
the most hated things in the shop like
hated tasks cyber sanding yeah exactly
and it's it's it's such a pain you know
you have to have all these different
sanding tools to get different shapes
and this and that and often one of the
biggest challenges is getting into
little areas you know little corners or
like organic shapes yeah introducing
sand hands its gloves with like a velcro
backing are you gonna tell me this
exists no but this is funny it's funny
okay you have like a Velcro velcro on
one side of your gloves and then you
have little um patches of sandpaper it's
not like a full handprint shape that
would wrinkle but you have patches for
your fingertips and your palm and your
thumb or that you can just like rub down
your piece just really massage it and
sand it you get all those organic shapes
you can just shimmy ya goin I think I
like sand and sand ants I can leave uh
sandy hands well think about it okay
let me pitch you my companion sandy no
it's called shadow gloves have you ever
been like in a situation where you're
wearing gloves and they get dirty but
you need to touch something
so well you do these gloves have 25
layers within them there 25 gloves and
one it's a couple gloves forever double
gloves forever like if this keeps on
going so it's like they're kind of thin
they're kind of thin yeah you know but
like the durability is in the layers you
know but like let's say you're like
you're gonna be doing some resin work
you put on shudder gloves and then what
you do you get like resin on your own oh
but then there's a little tab there you
pull it then you have fresh gloves right
there clean up loves in one that's so
good oh man gloves at first I thought
you're saying cheddar gloves and I was a
little doubtful we might need to work on
the name we might need to work on the
name I wasn't fully sure about that name
but infinite glove like infinity 25 and
me 25 layers and where the inspiration
came if you haven't watched some of our
resin videos you may not know this but
Evan is a big proponent of double glove
and you always tells me I should double
glove and I never do and I regret it
said it was cheddar cheddar Grove
okay okay steel flops are those
flip-flops made with tubers for the
points matter - okay okay
one two three four yeah right mmm all
right all right
so this shark hi so have you ever been
in this situation where your hands are
full but you need to turn on your vacuum
your your shop collection your desk last
name what's called let me introduce you
to vac you
with you kappa lights v.i.c why are um
okay thank you
back you it's it's you it's you focus
you controlled it's a it's a voice
controlled vacuum system so that like
when you go and cut make your first cut
and your hands are full and you're like
oh no I forgot the dust collection you
say like vacuum turn on what if it can't
hear you because it's so loud it's
specifically toned to human voices and
it ignores everything else I mean you
picked you any practical ideas that's
actually like super brilliant cuz like
so many times we were like ah dang it
dust collection but that's like far away
and it's like we have every like camera
set up and everything yeah and they're
like you might need to turn it off
manually but you can turn it on with
your voice I mean I think it's only
practical if you can turn it off
also I mean I know I know so that you
can turn on with like like like like
vacuum turn on yeah it's like you can
even train it you can train it I mean
thank you I'm saving my worst for last
okay
actually no no I have I have one that I
think is good okay this this I think is
good alright and it's related alright
tell me okay you know how hose adapters
are so freaking annoying yes because
nothing matches up with anything else
why not harness the power of the vacuum
itself and have vacuum-formed hose
adapters where they start out loose and
you put them in the space in between
your two tubes that you're trying to
connect
and the vacuum pulls and seals them
around it it's a good idea ignore like
physics it's like if it's if it's
elastic enough to deform it may not be
strong enough to create a solid
connection it doesn't have to be that
elastic just like a plastic bag do you
lose these suction force no no once it
seals its it's sealed you're not you
don't have any leaks and then when you
turn off the vacuum does the coupling
disconnect yeah so you gotta leave it on
actually it doesn't really work with
vacuum very well I don't know there's
there's once it once it it sucks
suctions on then you can twist a little
knob on the side of it that locks it
nanotechnology like this nanobots that
like like detect on/off states yeah no
solution expensive only $2,000 a piece
but they're reusable forever
you could only you just need one for
your [ __ ] out of passed I'll give you a
high five for that sir Wow me okay
what's what's like a really big issue in
a small shop we deal with it all the
time
space space exactly and what's one of
the things that takes up so much of our
space our international portal well
besides that workbench well it starts
with a W but it's not work bench wood
wood exact so much wood and you
want to throw it away or get rid of it
cuz you don't want to do that use it
yeah and you know unless you're blending
it up for what loot loot food pass so
you want to store it but you know when
you are working in a normal two car
garage it's a it's tough you know your
ceilings are only eight feet tall it's
really hard to fit long lumber I forgot
what I called it right to buy floor it
is you you it's a service and a product
the service part you have someone come
to your garage they get a jack hammer
and a chisel out a space in your floor a
compartment and then you put a trapdoor
on it in your garage and the trapdoor is
like a four by eight a little bit bigger
than a four by eight size so you can put
full sheet goods in there you can fit
long two by fours and it's just in your
floor it's easy access you don't have to
you know lift things from high above
your head how are you gonna lift like
large thick sheets of plywood up you'd
get a crane above you no you just pick
them up the floor is just like picking
it up off the ground it's not that deep
no no no no no it's not a pea deep it's
a feet wide it's like imagine like it's
like a foot deep I was thinking like an
8 foot deep hole knows that trench don't
be ridiculous
so it's like a basement no it's like
it's like you know how in movies when
people pull up like floor blue
floorboards yeah and they have like like
a lunch box full of stickers and stuff
in there I don't know people keep it's
like just like a little like a foot or
two of space it's like it's like that
it's just you know you don't want to
have so much that it's what what happens
when you sell the house and someone
wants to park their car there you refill
it with concrete he's easy easy easy
easy beauty look I'm giving you nothing
why don't you just uh get a wood printer
and then this keep a vat of wood in the
corner and then just print wood whenever
you need it no
it doesn't work you can't print solid
two-by-fours or can't print plywood you
know that's terrible guys nothing here
was made up and the points do matter so
final score guys what is it you were
keeping track it's three versus four
okay okay
you are better salesperson hi guys
thanks for joining us on this episode of
make pink no felting fell back episode
of Caitlyn podcast that too yeah yeah
yeah yeah let's do it okay so so what
what is my thing of the week oh I know
are you asking me yeah I forgot for a
second alright guys so I was using this
other day and I like thought about how
many times has come in handy it's not
something I use all the time but it's
really nice to have in your arsenal of
things so have you ever been like like
left with a screw and you wonder what
thread and pitch it is and like you just
want to like get more of the same or if
you have a nut or like a device or
you're trying to fix something and you
don't know what thread it is there's
this thing called the thread checker and
basically it has a male and female of
every single size metric and uá ê uá ê
uá know you and UNF and now I'm gonna
look SAE no SAE oh geez
and it lets you like verify any type of
thread is it great yeah they're super
handy and it comes on like a little
string right it has all little pieces
you pull it out of your pocket looks so
cool that's real cool it does look cool
alright what's your what's your thing
mine is related in name but not in what
it is
kind of okay terrible segue so your your
your thing is a thread thread checker
sad checker mine is a series of videos
by thread banger YouTube channel okay so
you guys you might have seen on
Instagram that we recently signed with
Lowe's yeah and about a year ago we met
Robin crane from thread Bangor and they
were telling us about how they were
working with Lowe's at the time to redo
their house and it was like old 1920s
house
and they were working on a series on it
it was bad so at the time we were like
and this is long before we were talking
with Lowe's we're like oh man we want to
we gotta check that out and we put it on
our to watch list and we just never got
around to it cuz yeah our to watch list
is ridiculous and the only has 356 items
on it I'm like nah joke yeah and so when
we resign Lowe's recently we were like
oh man it reminded us that we had never
checked out their videos so we started
watching the series I think it's like a
seven or nine part series where they're
fixing up their house it's so good it's
so good it's so good it's like it you
know it definitely has some HGTV vibes
because of the scale of the projects
they're doing but with YouTube realness
you know and YouTube like goofiness and
like non-professional 'no sin a good way
you know yeah we're on like episode 4 or
something maybe and it's just crazy the
amount of stuff they do and it
definitely got us thinking about you
know our current house needs some minor
projects you know we still have some
minor things and I list but what they're
doing is like total gut job on the house
like it's a lot well I think it's also
really cool to like use like your
partnership with a company to make good
content that you wouldn't be able to
make otherwise yeah I think it's like a
win-win-win because you know the brand
is getting exposure the the youtubers
are getting to tackle something that
they wouldn't have otherwise been able
to tackle yeah and the audience is
getting really interesting unique
content that they're the people like the
craters that they watch wouldn't have
been able to make without
sport yeah so this is really cool yeah
it's super cool and it's just really
well done so far and we're really liking
and it got me thinking like you know if
in the future we do end up getting a new
house like I'm sure if we get a new
house we're gonna get one that needs a
little work because you know if you get
something it's already finished you
don't have to work on it but then like
everything that's there asset you feel
really weird like oh well I don't like
the color of these brand new cabinets so
I'm gonna rip them out and get you guys
if they're crappy cabinets that you feel
no guilt you know so like I think it
leaves me personally I prefer something
that needs a little work because then
that allows you to customize it the way
you want it without feeling guilty about
like tearing out brand-new perfectly
fine stuff yeah um so I first see us if
we do get a new house getting something
that needs a little work
yeah and so I think it was cool seeing
the way that they have been doing the
series because it gives me ideas you
know if we were going to do something
like that and I don't know if we would
ever get like a gut job like a full gut
job the house is from like the 1920s so
it was like taken down to the studs but
I just think it it's interesting kind of
thinking about how we would do it if we
did something like that that's exciting
alrighty guys well thank you so much for
listening and watching
and or watching to today's podcast we
actually did a video on how we set all
of this up like you know all of the the
iterations we went through and all of
the equipment we're using so if you're
interested in that we're also gonna be
linking to that video down below good
idea and so check that out if you're
interested but like the one asked we
have is today if you liked the episode
could you share it with one person
yeah awesome with or without context
yeah a person mom's love us
[Music]
most coffee I'll have it after so I
don't have to poop me too episode